this something quite primal about the
entry something that just feels really
safe it's just green go climb a tree an
arborist is somebody who takes care of
the tree we prune maintain remove the
thing just really the whole health care
of the tree in Melbourne we're quite
lucky in the ranges this trees up there
85 90 metres really really big trees at
the moment I'm about 24 23 24 meters up
a tree and a beautiful over exam this
old tree we're in today is maybe 250
years old and it would be such a shame
to the landscape to lose something
rubbish
[Music]
is it dangerous I probably a yeah must
be really dangerous it means one of the
most dangerous jobs in the world
apparently every single tree has
something different you have to put into
it that hole is just big enough to take
one of the fringes and hopefully prevent
all these leaf miners from effectively
working with trees and understanding
tree and having a respect to trees is
the only way I think you can really then
cut the trees
the thing is sometimes a tree needs to
come down if there's an obvious failure
or disease or something then with the
best ones to come out remove it safely
and advise about how we can replant
we're here actually trying to preserve
and look after the trees because we very
much have an affection for them
I kind of compare it with being at a
giant dog park some of them love it like
you start giving them armpit scratches
and they're just like giant dog they
just aren't rolling around and they're
flying all around you but these animals
are huge people are intimidated by them
but with you
once you learn their behavior they're
just right into you right away they just
look at you like a big chew toy I could
never see myself living anywhere other
than the Pacific Northwest
I could literally spend every single
Nadel the rest of my life and never
travel anywhere other than Vancouver
Island and I would still never have
enough time to see this whole place my
first introduction to the ocean would
have definitely come from my mom
Nealon right there later on in life
realize it is a pretty unique experience
to get to host spend time with these
animals on a regular basis
sea lions are large intelligent animal
and they're very sensitive of what your
intentions are and and how they choose
interact with you it's totally their
choice if you're comfortable and they're
inquisitive they'll come and they'll
chew on your fan do they know I'm gonna
chew on the edge of your mask or give
you a big kisses on the lips or big hugs
they wrap their fins around you and give
you a big hug
[Music]
people get sketched out about it like
I've had lots people contacting me like
don't you think those things are
aggressive just because an animal's
putting its mouth on you doesn't mean
it's doing it in a harmful way they
don't have hands they can explore their
world with anything other than their
mouth there's people that spend a lot of
money to travel to the other side of the
planet to watch a group of large
migratory animals in Africa or something
say and here I can just go out on my
boat and it's not something I take for
granted at all anymore having the
opportunity to do this
[Music]
I've been skiing since I was four years
old my name is Claudia and I ski orbit
working I spent most part of a year
close to the mountain
when I spend time away from it
I feel nostalgic likely something is
missing to my soul to my life and in
this moment I take my ski and I go up
[Music]
Mount Etna is located on the east coast
of Sicily is known as the tallest and
axis was done unto you
the risk climbing Mount Etna are the
same of any other mountain
you have to be careful and respect
sports brandade
the view from the top is unique you can
see the landscape change many times from
cream foods to desert volcanic area all
the lava flow and the coarse black
powder is volcanic sand and its format
during the eruption it's incredible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but I believe in
[Music]
day-to-day living I find it can be
pretty mundane and you know when I'm out
there you've just got a really simple
task which is to survive and enjoy life
my name is Gavin McClurg and I'm a
cross-country paraglider yeah we're
basically for flying a modified bedsheet
and strings we don't have a motor and
we're just using the thermals thermals
are kind of like the gas for a car we
get as high as we possibly can and then
we glide and if we find another thermal
we can keep going
I've flown in Himalayas I've flown and
Morocco have flown all over the Alps in
Europe in the Canadian Rockies and we're
just looking at a map in a completely
different way these days Hurricane Ridge
is one of the most spectacular places
for me in the world this beautiful long
Ridge that ties right in with the Grand
Canyon sits right on the edge as I on
national park I was doing this
expedition with some of the best pilots
in the world and right is the Sun set
you know the conditions just went bang
on and we all launched into the sky and
you know paragliding can be really
intense and sometimes really scary and
very dangerous and this was like the
opposite of that it was just playful and
fun and we were doing huge wing overs
and acro and when I'm flying over these
really remote places I think what it
gives you is a perspective and in awe
that it's impossible to get in any other
way
these guys and I are people that you
know we really chase records and we
chase huge distances and made us realize
that you know it's not about the records
and it's not about client each distance
it is just about enjoying the freedom of
flight
[Music]